le 28e hiver commence pour les restos du
cœur de plaisir et le nombre des
bénéficiaires de l'aide alimentaire
explose 65 % de hausse en 6 ans avec ce
constat la fréquentation des femmes
seules avec enfants a triplé c'est la
première fois que je viens ici parce que
j'ai pas beaucoup d'argent alors je
viens ici depuis plusieurs années on a
une augmentation importante des femmes
soles avec enfants quelque fois de TR
enfants quelque chose de très important
les femmes ont été les premières à pâtir
de la crise du coup les restos du cœur
s'organisent les 70 bénévoles formés à
l'accueil et à l'accompagnement Orient
les femmes vers les assistantes sociales
ou la CAF mais aussi vers l'accès aux
soins tous les mardis après-midi une
puircultrice ou une diététicienne
reçoivent les mamans le but privilégier
le partage et l'échange et pas seulement
la distribution de denrées alimentaires
rose bénéficiaire de longue date avec
son mari et son fils accompagne sa fille
qui vient de s'inscrire avec son enfant
de 5 ans ce sont parfois des familles
entières qui tombent dans la précarité
une précarité qui peut durer il y a
quelques années quand même déjà
8 8 ans on a un emploi on travaille un
emploi on travaille on enregistré mais
c'est pas facile la vie est pas facile
quoi du tout l'an dernier les restosx du
cœur de plaisir ont accueilli 375
familles et ici depuis 15 jours les
inscriptions pour les mois à venir ont
commencé avec une recrudescence de 15 à%
par rapport à